I gotta ask you about this I was
surprised we watched the footage of you
and Colton's breakup and I was surprised
by how well you took it I mean you were
crying that you weren't mad what was
going through your mind at that point
were you shocked and how did you keep it
together honestly I'm just going back to
the pre-interview and you're just like
tell me what you really think about it
okay anyway um I mean tell me what you
really think about it yeah Lauren had
the hard-hitting questions and I was
like Oh next question okay no honestly
during that breakup I felt like I was
consoling him because he was so upset
and it bothered me to see him upset and
I was appreciative that he told me when
he did he knew that he wasn't giving me
what I deserved and what I knew I was
ready for and all I could do in that
moment was know that he fully tried I
feel like it happened exactly how it
needed to so we could both realize that
we are not for each other and so we can
both move on your best friend Raven has
questioned this to Colton's intentions
where do you stand on them today what do
you think of what he wants to get out of
reality TV
I don't think Colson has bad intentions
but I also don't think that he is
necessarily ready for a serious
relationship
like I was I mean you could see that and
I've been questioned him in the first
week and said if you know that you're
not ready if you know you're indecisive
what are you doing here you know no one
can can force you into this so if you're
not ready what are you what are you
doing it is how does Raven feel about it
is she saying I told you so or what she
said
yeah Raven didn't say I told you so but
I would never want to think that he has
bad intentions I mean you can say you're
here for the right reasons wrong reasons
whatever but because there's a lot of
talk now about him potentially being The
Bachelor yeah how would you feel about
that I mean it was just when did we film
that June I mean it was just about two
months ago that I was telling him that
he really needs
figure himself out before he can fully
be with someone else so if there's a
chance that Colton is the bachelor I
would hope he is fully ready for that
experience knowing that he wants to be
engaged at the end of it do you think
he's ready
I vote Jason for bachelor so you don't
think Cole is ready we haven't really
had those conversations since paradise
obviously it's been guys have been
talking every day I don't know that he's
ready I don't how are you able to be
friends with him after all those
emotions are you over him at this point
yeah I'm telling you it's the weirdest
the weirdest thing like it just I don't
know if it's because we had so much
emotion I cried every freaking day and
it just got to where it was like you
know what you really put yourself
through the wringer with this one too
yeah really it's our mess and I mean it
happened it didn't work and it's okay
you